Here is a cell on your screen.
We have already seen that the various organelles
inside it are compactly packed inside this
delicate membrane called the cell membrane
or plasma membrane!
We have even seen that the cell membrane makes
use of diffusion process to transport gas
and water molecules in and out of the cell.
However, Diffusion is not the only process employed.
There are a few more in the list.
Let us have a look at these methods in this video.
Tell me one thing, how do we transport water
from a lower height to a higher height?
We need a pump.
Because this does not happen on its own.
A force or some energy is required to pull
the water upwards.
Similarly in a cell, some molecules have to
be carried inside or moved outside the cell.
This requires energy to be spent.
The energy used is the form of ATP molecules.
This is called as ACTIVE Transport.
That is, ACTIVE transport requires expenditure
of energy.
The transportation is carried out by protein
molecules present on the cell membrane.
On the other hand, diffusion, does not require energy.
Hence it is a type of PASSIVE TRANSPORT.
So movement of molecules without spending
energy as in case of diffusion is passive
transport.
Similarly, movement of molecules across the
membrane with the expense of energy is active
transport!
Now let us get to know one more interesting
concept named OSMOSIS.
Have we ever come across this term OSMOSIS?
Well, quite often!
But what exactly do we mean by this?
Osmosis is defined as the movement of water
from higher water concentration to lower water
concentration through a semi permeable membrane.
So let us say we have this container which
is partitioned by this semi permeable membrane.
Now we add sugar solutions at both these sides.
However, the concentration of each is different.
Here we add concentrated sugar solution while
here, dilute sugar solution.
That means the concentration of water in this
solution is obviously more compared to this!
So after some time, we see water molecules
moving from this side of the partition to
this side.
And how long will this movement take place?
It will occur till the concentration of water
is balanced, that is equalized on both the
sides!
This is nothing but osmosis!
Let us learn some more interesting concepts
about osmosis and cell transport in the next
video!